all of a sudden from behind me
a killer stabbed me several times wes
craven
he said do you think that you could
scream just a little louder i said i can
do that
after doing her best to tell sydney
stupid people go back smart people run
i end up stabbed my character died when
she
fell off the roof after ghost face
chased her
it's probably one of the more gruesome
deaths of all
she ultimately gets uh stabbed in the
stomach
several times and is completely gutted i
was
attacked from behind that wasn't going
down easy
it was pretty brutal his own girlfriend
jill first shot him
in the nuts i wanted to die with my eyes
open
and i asked if i could do that and he
said yes
so i got to really gag on the blood and
then do the dead eye
falling down a flight of stairs getting
crushed under a garage door and
ultimately being offed by the iconic
ghost face
i was stabbed in the back in the stomach
by ghost face himself
because i was too distracted looking at
my phone but if there's a life lesson to
take out of it it's
you know get off your phone i was
courtney's cameraman and i got my throat
slit
and my death was one of them that caused
an x-rated wes had to trim some frames
to get an arm
[Music]
you